[Music]
chris is in boston massachusetts hey
chris what's up
mr ramsay thank you so much for taking
my call it's an honor honor to speak
with you sir how can i help
well i'm wondering if you can help me
decide whether or not to keep or sell my
motorcycle
okay so um on baby step two
i started a little over two and a half
years ago um
started at 163 i'm down to 71 000
so it's going pretty good way to go but
uh
but thank you but um you know now that
the finish line's getting closer i'm
just trying to figure out anything
extra i can do i already have three jobs
the motorcycle's like my little
oasis but if i sell it i can probably
get you know about sixteen thousand
dollars for it or so
which would bump me up by about six
months and paying off my debt
and and you have a car i'll take it i
take it the motorcycle's a toy it's for
enjoyment
yes and what's your household income i
make about sixty six thousand dollars a
year
what is your car worth
it's a hooptie it's probably only worth
about three thousand dollars
so your motorcycle's worth five times
what your car is worth
yes that's pass backwards
yeah i got the bike before i found out i
know i know i'm just saying
the net result is still there right yeah
i mean
you don't know anything wrong i mean
this is it's just a it's a valid good
question you've got
so um
it's completely up to you you're not out
of line on your numbers
okay you're going to be debt free inside
of two years
either way right yes
it's about 22 months if i don't sell it
and yeah
yeah and my rule of thumb is simply you
know
if it got you out of debt if it was
going to be three years and it got you
out of debt in two years i would have
done it because anything over two years
i start to
i start to get the quivers i start to
shake i want you i want you out of there
faster than that with your gazelle
intensity because dude you are you are
game on i mean you're working every job
you're not doing anything
you've got no life the only life you've
got it's a motorcycle occasionally but
you don't have time to write it because
all you do is work
and so you know you're you're doing
everything the way i did
and the way i teach people to do to get
yourself free right you want freedom
of course yeah so i don't think there's
anything wrong with keeping the bike and
there's nothing wrong with you saying
i'm going to accelerate this
someday soon i'll buy another bike
after i upgrade in car and
uh you know the total of everything with
motors and wheels should not be over
half your annual income you've probably
heard me say that it's too much invested
in things that go down in value
and bikes and cars and boats and sea
doos and
all the other crap we buy four-wheelers
with uh motors in them they all go down
in value
and golf carts yeah that's another one
and uh
gotta have one of those to drive around
the hoa apparently apparently the car
won't work there
but the uh um so yeah anyway this crap
we all buy
um so yeah it's okay to keep it because
you're gonna be under two years
and what would i do if i woke up in your
shoes
[Music]
ah i'd be on the bubble because i want
to be out of debt so fast but i also
hear you that it's your
it's your oasis my always is my boat if
it was my boat what would i do
[Music]
i'd probably sell it if it was my boat
and get another boat later
and give me a little better car because
the thing's three times five times what
your car's worth
that's bothersome too